The joe rogan experience.
The other,
another experience I had,
I've had in recent years,
it led me to not want to engage in this is,
is walking around various events in sort of breakout things,
see people who,
you know,
we need people I've admired in the past all saying things like you,
you see that as you see I flamed x on Twitter.
I do you see what I tweeted about that person?
I,
I think these used to be serious people and these used to be serious people
engaged in serious things and here they are engaged in these full flailing fist
fights and often,
often let's face it on things,
which if you didn't do it like that,
seeking out the fight are the sort of thing that would allow for normal human
interaction.
I mean how many disagreements that we have with people in our personal lives all
the time.
If we wanted to,
uh,
you didn't vote this way that way.
I mean some people would mind about that.
But you know,
I,
I know you've,
you think slightly differently from me on this particular issue.
You,
you don't say let's have that out now once and for all you,
um,
you,
you find ways to live with,
with difference and different opinions and you know,
I mean,
you're not going to get everyone exactly in line.
we all knew that before the age of social media and now it seems to be the only
aim.
What do you think that is?
It,
I mean think it's what we were discussing earlier,
that it's idea sport and then you just get caught up and like someone volleyed
your way and so you have to smash that tennis ball back there where it is.
Something like that.
I mean,
I,
I can't say I haven't felt the vicarious pleasure of some of that myself,
you know,
so that old Chinese proverb about sitting by the river,
watching the bodies of your enemies float by.
Um,
I had a big sense of that the other day when somebody I deeply disliked came
across her on social media at the same time as somebody else I deeply dislike
was being held by the French police on serious charges.
And I thought that was a,
I felt like the Chinese proverb.
That's all right.
And so I,
I can,
I can see why people feel it.
Sure.
Um,
and of course people who they could never normally get to who they've got to.
I mean,
I think that's,
I think that's the big,
uh,
the big thing of,
you know,
look,
I poked that.
You know what?
Yeah,
they never engage on social media for precisely that reason,
that reason of my others that you would never,
I would never want somebody to know they could get to me,
even if they,
even if you just block them,
there's many people who take pride even in their heading,
they say,
I am blocked on Twitter by all these people.
And,
and actually I do sometimes read what people say,
send to me.
Um,
and I've never blocked anyone because I sort of think you should mind,
is that if you put your ideas out there,
you might as well be as open as possible to receiving them back.
Some time ago when I got into a vow with,
uh,
with the Turkish president about,
about something,
uh,
I got all these Turkish,
a sort of accounts sending me stuff.
There was one guy,
he just repeated these sent me,
uh,
pornography of animals
having sex with,
so I don't know,
it just,
it was very,
it was very hard core and um,
and so I used to go down the feet.
Now that gun,
I didn't even block him actually because I sort of thought,
well,
somewhere in Turkey,
he's a really angry man,
desperately finding horse pornography send,
sending to me.
And in a way I felt so sorry for him that that was how his life had Karma,
the end,
his life and come to at this stage that I,
I couldn't even block him.
And also he'd be like,
I'm the donkey porn guy who got blocked by dog.
He'd get a certain fame.
Do you think that they're just caught up in this sexy thing?
Yes.
A lot of it is sensationalism.
It's also what the public is really focused on right now.
So it's something that gathers ratings.
I think they're driving it.
I think it's driven from the top down,
from the establishment media Dow,
from the Democrats down.
Because again,
if you talk to regular people,
they're fucking hurting,
right?
We just have been stagnant since 1980 there's 30 million people that don't have
healthcare in Trump's first year in office,
3 million more people lost healthcare because he did all these executive orders
that basically took a hatchet to Obamacare.
So you have all these people who are really hurting their,
they care about their wages.
They care about,
you know,
not being saddled with over a trillion dollars in student loan debt.
This is the shit regular people care about.
So if when they turn on CNN and they see Russia,
Russia,
even if you don't like Trump,
I despise Trump with every fiber of my fucking mean.
But when I see this,
I wrote my fucking eyes and then they have the nerve to say,
oh,
Trump won't shut up about Russia.
You were talking about her all day and he responded to it and because he
responds it to it,
you're like,
oh,
there he goes again with Russia.
Yeah,
it's going to be interesting to see how this all plays out.
I'm really fascinated and I'm fascinated to see if he can make it out of four
years.
Well not only,
well I think he's going to,
do you think he's gonna run my thing?
He's gonna run again and he's going to win again.
He has a chance.
He has a fucking chance because the Democrats,
if the Democrats run Kamala Harris,
if they run Cory booker or any of the other corporatists he can win because he's
going to go right back into his tap dance about being a populous and helping
people.
And guess what?
In the first few years of his tax bill,
regular people did get a tax cut.
So he's going to say,
look,
you look at your tax bill.
I just gave you an extra thousand dollars this year.
Who you want to vote for?
And so there is an argument that he's going to make to the people.
And if you don't have somebody like Bernie Sanders or Bernie Sanders talking
about the issues that matter to people will then of course he can fucking win
again.
Listen there,
there was,
I was laughed at when I said,
if it's Donald Trump and Hillary Clinton,
he can win.
People laughed at me.
We have a soft life now.
So there's Gunna be a lot of people that are ridiculous.
And you know,
there's always been those people that are weak willed and they want the world to
be nerved up and of course pad their feelings.
You're,
you're going to have that.
But there's also more people that have an understanding of like,
that's not a happy,
healthy way to live your life.
And I also think that like reality at some point will always supersede nerf
padding.
You know,
there's always going to be a push back on that where you go look like,
I don't want to offend anybody,
but like,
you know,
and I do agree that like there's a movement by the left that really does push,
I was,
I did a thing,
reason.
I'm doing this a charity event,
um,
for uh,
like an urban program for kids.
Um,
mainly inner city black kids and I'm hosting it with my,
uh,
my buddy Mike Yard.
He's a really funny comic black dude and we went to meet with the guys for this
charity and they were telling us that,
uh,
you know,
they have an auction,
like any charity event,
right?
An auctioneer comes out and they all try to auction off and raise a lot of money
from rich people to help the program.
That's a very basically 99.9% of every charity event I've ever been involved.
This has an auction segment in the dinner.
Right.
They were like,
we're going to have that,
but we can't use the word auction.
I said,
what?
What do you mean you can't use the word auction?
Don't like,
it's a sensitive word for,
you know the community.
I was like,
and then yard goes,
are you talking about slave?
It's like kids head office six flood.
He was like,
wait,
we can,
and I was like,
wait,
we can't say the word auction.
I'm like,
but aren't you hiring a guy from Southerby's?
Yeah,
his card's going to say auctioneer on it.
We're just going to pretend that's not what he's called.
And they were just like,
we just don't feel comfortable with that word in the room.
And I was just going to,
I can't see,
I said,
guys,
I got to tell you,
like you're making me want to vote for Trump.
That's what I said.
I said,
that's how dumb I think this is.
Okay.